once again, wildfires are ravaging California
and the president is doing what no president
should,
which is vowing no more federal aid to California.
At this key time, Trump and right-wingers
have been using the California wildfires to
spread what is a combination of anti-science
nonsense, but also sort of like the most toxic
version of partisan politics that you can
imagine, which is when people's lives are
at stake.
I actually saw a clip last week of Fox news
host, Tucker Carlson and cultural critic Dave
Ruben saying, you can blame the wildfires
on left wing wokeness and political correctness.
Trump has previously said all sorts of nonsense
about the wild wildfires as well, including
how this is all the fault of forest management,
which he has no idea what that even means.
The latest fires are really bad.
The last, I looked over 200,000 acres of land
destroyed people fleeing homes.
115 hundred and 25 maybe a structures that
have been damaged by the fires, at least three
people killed so far, that number, sadly maybe
climbing.
So what does Donald Trump do?
He tweets insults at the California governor
Gavin Newsome and says no more aid for California.
Quote, the governor of California, Gavin Newsome
has done a terrible job of forest management.
I told him from the first day we met that
he must clean his forest floors regardless
of what his bosses, the environmentalist's
demand of him must also do burns and cut fire
stoppers every year as the fires rage, fire,
apostrophe S by the way, as the fires rage,
the rage belonging to the fires and California
burns, it is the same thing.
And then he comes to the federal government
for money help no more get your act together.
Governor, you don't see close to the level
of burn and other States.
Yeah, because their circumstances are totally
different.
Topographically, but our teams are putting
our working well together in putting these
massive many fires out.
Great firefighters also open up the ridiculously
closed water lanes coming down from the North.
Don't pour it out into the Pacific ocean should
be done immediately.
California desperately needs water and you
can have it now.
Gavin Newsome immediately shooting back on
Twitter that Trump shouldn't even really be
talking about this because he doesn't even
accept climate science saying quote, you don't
believe in climate change.
You are excused from there from this conversation,
so there's a lot here that's sick.
Now of course, if you're the president and
you tell a state, one of the States that you
are also the president for, you tell a state
that's suffering from horrible wildfires that
you're cutting off aid.
It's disgusting.
People are dying literally because of the
fires.
Second, Trump talking about water lanes from
the North.
This guy has no idea what he's talking about.
I mean truly no idea.
He's referring to these rules that don't allow
farmers to drain all the water from rivers
and you have to let some of the water flow
into the oceans naturally as the planet is
supposed to work.
And Donald Trump is apparently furious with
that.
He thinks that some kind of leftist, uh, mismanagement
to allow rivers to function.
Normally.
Donald Trump is then using people's homes
and property and lives their lives here being
lost to be flippant about climate change and
to throw political retribution at a state
that he doesn't like.
It has a democratic governor.
He's constantly embattled with Nancy Pelosi,
Congresswoman from California, but California
is filled with both Democrats and Republicans.
Not that should even matter, not that it should
even make a difference because they're all
Americans.
I hope that historians are properly documenting
everything that is taking place here so that
the CIC and viral nature of this administration
isn't lost to history because that would be
a tragedy.
The administration is tragic.
It's actions are tragic, but forgetting the
horrors of this administration would also
be tragic.
And if this guy wins reelection, this exact
kind of pettiness, although it sounds to call
it pettiness, is too soft, right?
It's more than pettiness is worse than that.
This is what we would expect to be in overdrive
if Donald Trump is reelected and knows that
he doesn't have another election to win or
to deal with at the tail end.
Is this how cheap life has become under Donald
Trump, homeless children, kids in cages?
Who cares?
There are political points to score.
Fires are killing people.
Well, the governor is a Democrat and some
something, something rivers and ocean.
No more aid for you.
It's horrifying.
And imagine what lessons our kids are being
taught implicitly by this president.
When you have a president that behaves this
way and children see it, what lessons are
we teaching kids based on the behavior of
this madman?
Truly sad and hopefully without Trump's help,
uh, they can get the wildfire situation under
control.
In California,